this is a very very serious debate and
although we've had a lot of very
entertaining speeches
it is important to try to clarify what
the differences are between our
positions so I'm going to be a little
bit boring to begin
right the key point about this debate is
it is about rewilding the Uplands
it is not about whether or not we care
about nature in Britain
so we need to begin absolutely by
acknowledging that a lot of what George
and Mark have said is 100
absolutely true
there has been a terrible loss in
Britain
particularly
since 1940s since the Second World War
in terms of beauty
in terms of Wildlife
in terms of meaning
a loss of that has unfortunately been
driven
through the 40s 50s and 60s by
agricultural policy long before anybody
joined the European Union
an enormous amount of damage has also
been done by forestry Plantation
damage has been done by cities
damage has also been done by abandonment
of land
all of this together means that
everything that George and Mark have
said in terms of environmental damage is
absolutely correct and I'm not here in
any way to challenge their erudition
their knowledge
the question is how do we respond to
this and in particular do we respond to
this in terms of this motion which is
and is only about
rewilding the Uplands
now that means that I have to deal with
two quite different people here right
one of them of course is George now it's
extremely difficult arguing against a
man of such immense hutzpah erudition
able to quote Thomas More off the top of
his head who talks sometimes than
Guardian articles about his delight at
the notion of reintroducing the ancient
elephant and the Rhino only to change
positions and suggest he doesn't really
mean that he means the wolf and the
links who talks about creating two
serengetis in Europe and then shifts
back to saying perhaps Britain is too
small I ought to know how difficult it
is to argue against someone like this I
ought to know how difficult it is to try
to make small detailed reasonable
arguments against someone like this I
worked for Boris Johnson
[Applause]
now
mark on the other hand
is making a different kind of argument
Mark is making a very very powerful
argument for the British environment
but very little of his argument if you
listen to it carefully was about
rewilding or about rewilding the Uplands
he talked with immense passion and
conviction about the loss of butterflies
many of those butterflies would not
flourish in the close canopy temperate
rainforest that George mombio is
imagining appearing through a re-wilded
Uplands many of the species which have
been evoked by Mark's powerful speech
and this might even extend to lap wings
and curl you may also not flourish in a
close forested or even scrubbed
environment
it's also true that much of the loss
that he's talking about in terms of
ponds and a lot of the arguments he's
making around industrial agriculture
simply barely apply to the Uplands of
England
that industrial architecture
enshrined in the agriculture I quote the
words that he's using he's talking about
arable monoculture he's talking about
rectilineal pastoral systems these are
simply not characteristic of the Uplands
in fact most of the land that George is
concerned about most of the Uplands that
he's concerned about and with reason
then he has strong arguments here most
of that is simply not rectilineal it
hasn't received large amounts of
fertilizer it hasn't received large
amounts of pesticide effectively the
claim that George is making is that the
Uplands have been overstocked but that's
not the only claims that he's making and
I'm going to be a little bit boring just
for 45 seconds to try to point out why
it's quite important to focus on the
claims that are actually being made and
I'm sorry if I'm sounding a little bit
legalistic here in that amazingly
Charming Exposition by George he began
with a great fact
he produced the great vision
Europe in general has 37 Woodland cover
Britain by contrast has only 13 percent
and what is responsible for this it is
subsidies and in particular the
subsidies of the European Union
what is the problem with this argument
problem with this argument is that
Woodland cover today in Britain is
larger than any time since the 14th
century the entire amount of Woodland
cover in Britain in 1900 was three
percent would George like to explain
exactly how we went from three percent
coverage in 1900 to 13 coverage today
and somehow it's all the fault of
European Union subsidies
shades of Boris Johnson begin to appear
in my mind right
and the reason why I'm doing this is
that it is quite important to understand
what's really going on and it's quite
important to understand the kind of
solutions that George is proposing
not mark because as I say Mark is
basically making an argument that I 100
agree on Marx should be on this side of
the table Mark is arguing for good
environmental restoration projects and
in particular he's put a huge focus on
the catastrophic damage to our lowlands
the Uplands ironically contain most of
the triple sis in Britain it is exactly
because there has not been intensive
agriculture in the Uplands that we now
end up in the perverse situation that
environmentalists are trying to argue
for the displacement of farmers from the
Uplands as a reward for the fact that
those Farmers did not trash the
environment in the same way that the
lowlands were trashed instead of turning
around
180 degrees the basis of George's
argument George has stated in a guardian
article 2013 that there are three
reasons why we should concentrate on the
Uplands number one it is unproductive
land number two that it is far from
cities and number three that it is
sparsely populated those are exactly the
three reasons why we should be focusing
on environmental projects in the
lowlands
that fertile productive land is far more
capable of generating biodiversity
the key example of the kind of rewilding
we should be doing in this country and
by rewilding of course I don't mean
the visions of the Yellowstone National
Park that George sometimes tongue in
cheek evokes of wolves and lynxes and
great romping herbivores serengetis is
in fact what's happening in NEP in
Sussex at the moment a really strong
example of how taking three and a half
thousand acres of lowland Farm can
deliver species such as the Nightingale
such as the turtle dove which of course
do not live in the Uplands that loss of
the Nightingale has absolutely nothing
to do with the outlets again it should
be close to cities and close to
populated areas because the natural
Capital value lies partly as George
implies in humans getting into that
landscape
far more health benefits will accrue to
the populations if we did and this is my
radical proposal for you to take on
these radical proposals
if we rewilded the green belt
right if we planted trees all the way
around London then the benefits would be
extraordinary
school children would get out into that
environment the health benefits of
walking in that environment would follow
the air quality benefits that would
follow from foresting the Greenbelt in
terms of nitrogen dioxide and sulfur
dioxide emissions in London would be
astonishing
doing it in the Uplands achieves none of
these benefits and in so far as there is
a population in the Uplands it is
because of something I wish to finish on
the fundamental point
is firstly that these Upland farmers
are people who live there who own that
land who have rights and who are working
unbelievably hard day in day out to
preserve it but finally that the
landscape that they are preserving is
the landscape we dream of when we fight
on the Western Front that landscape of
wild Uplands and pasture of sheep and
dry stone walls embodies not just
history but meaning which is Central to
our identity